antoine des avions doivent partir de
russie aujourd'hui où tout à fait c'est
depuis une base militaire et une base
militaire située en banlieue de moscou
que décollent en fait depuis la journée
d'hier depuis dimanche des avions à
destination de l'italie des appareils
militaires à bord desquels se trouvent
des unités de désinfection mobile du
matériel médical mais aussi vous l'avez
dit du personnel soignant et des
médecins spécialistes une aide médicale
qui fait suite à une conversation
téléphonique entre le premier ministre
italien et vladimir poutine les
autorités russes ont accepté de venir en
aide à l'italie
tant que la situation en russie reste
sous contrôle et coûté neuf avions
iliouchine 76 de transport militaire des
forces aérospatiale russe ont transporté
près de 100 spécialistes militaires
russes du matériel et de l'équipement
depuis l'aérodrome militaire de
tchkalovski vers l'italie pour prêter
assistance dans le cadre de la lutte
contre le coronavirus et se sont même 10
avions qui sont partis depuis dimanche
le dixième ayant décollé aujourd'hui
dans l'après midi c'est donc une aide
qui est la bienvenue en italie je tiens
à exprimer la grande satisfaction et la
gratitude de tous les italiens pour
l'aide russe dans un moment aussi
difficile pour la république italienne
je tiens à vous remercier pour le
matériel et les spécialistes venus de
russie pour aider l'italie
sinon en russie le nombre de cas
confirmés est passé en 24 heures de 367
à 438 et à moscou en leur sens la
majorité de ces cas le maire de la ville
sergueï sobianine s'est adressé à ses
administrés pour leur soumettre de
nouvelles mesures en particulier à
destination des personnes âgées
désormais les personnes les plus
fragiles et celles âgées de plus de 65
ans sont invités à rester chez elle et a
arrêté de travailler le cas échéant des
services de livraison de médicaments à
domicile ou également des aides
financières ont été mises en place mais
pour le reste de la population
il ne s'agit que de recommandations et
le confinement strict que l'on connaît
en france par exemple n'est pas encore
de mise en russie merci anthony que
l'euro en direct
coût